you're such a pleasant nice person he
really is very nice there are
celebrities who will go nameless right
Andy who are at least now at least now
you haven't had any drink yeah so you
know they're out here in their pleasant
and in the minute the cameras are off
their monsters yeah yeah al roker Helen
Mirren oh boy this goes on and on and on
but but you you're always pleasant then
I'm thinking to myself today cuz I know
you're gonna be coming on the show
ok Elijah Wood does he ever completely
lose it does he ever do you ever just
have rage and when does that happen is
there anything that really sets you off
honestly no yeah except for in the car
so I have this thing where I feel like
I'm a secret [ __ ] when I'm driving so
I literally I can't bring myself to be
unkind to people so that you know I have
many many occasions where autograph
funds work um and will come up to me and
I know that they're selling these things
and it's I'm completely morally against
it but I can't help but sign it because
I don't want to turn someone down it's
against my nature however in a vehicle
the all bets are off and I will do
things that are so ridiculous where I'll
be driving you know someone will have
cut me off I'll curse at them and then
I'll I'll flip them off but below the
window you open the glove box and put
the middle finger in there
close it yeah that's crazy it is a
little crazy but I could kind of see how
it would vent something but you're in a
safe place a safe place nobody it's not
directed at anyone that they know of
yeah I can I can let the curses fly and
it gets gnarly in my car
it gets gnarly out here varying your
gesticulate you're swinging at the air
wildly still my favorite move because I
and I have to laugh at myself is the the
flipping them off below the window right
I literally do that like I won't I don't
have the courage to like actually engage
right I don't want to engage right but
I'm letting you have it and you have no
idea I've had moments of road rage where
I'm screaming somebody they're screaming
me and in the middle of them screaming I
see them recognize me so they're like oh
yeah well momentarily confused yeah yeah
yeah like I yeah it was Andy Richard
that just told me to blow myself or
whatever blow yourself
I was I was cleaning it up for the kids
oh okay oh yeah I wish you really did
say that whatever why don't you just
blow yourself
the invisible glasses yes I love
suggesting that someone gets into a
complicated physical position yeah I do
an impossible physical position yes if
someone told me to do that I'd be like
I'd have to have ribs removed yeah
I'm sorry it's my bad turn
my god I didn't know sometimes I really
getting this and I forget over the
sausage and there's people yeah you know
it's wrong it's wrong what I did and I
you